صور اربكت علماء الفضاء والفيزياء ست نقاط
حمراء في عمق الكون لكن وجودها يتناقض مع
النموذج الحالي للكون فالصور التي التقطها
تليسكوب جيمس ويب كشفت عن مجرات هائله
تعود الى عصور مبكره من عمر الوجود عصور
لا يمكن بحسب النظريات السائده ان تنمو
فيها مجرات عملاقه
ومكنت تقنيه استشعار الاشعه تحت الحمراء
تلسكوب الفضاء الشهير من رصد المجرات التي
تشكلت قرابه 500 سنه فقط بعدما يعرف
بالانفجار العظيم اي في مرحله لم يوجد
خلالها ما يكفي من الماده والوقت لتشكيل
مجرات تحتضن مئات الملايين من النجوم
حالها حال مجرتنا درب التبانه التي استغرق
نضوجها اكثر من ثلاثه عشر مليار سنه
وفق مجله نيتشر فان كلا من هذه المجرات
تزن مليارات المرات اكثر من شمسنا وهي
حمراء لان الكون يتمدد والضوء الذي يمر
عبره يتمدد ويصبح اطول موجيه واكثر
احمرارا
في السابق مجرتين من المجرات الست الا ان
الصور لم تكن واضحه
[موسيقى]
يستبعد بعض العلماء ان تكون هذه الاجسام
السته مجرات انما هي ماده شديده السخونه
تدور حول ثقب اسود وقد تكون مؤشرا على ان
الامور تسارعت في مراحل نشوء الكون بشكل
اكبر مما كان متوقعا او ان الس
ماء ما كنا نعتقد لصباح العربيه هند
ابراهيم واشنطن